ya acaban de una pequeña ciudad de
uganda a 20 km de la frontera con la
República democrática del Congo cada día
cientos de refugiados llegan a este
campo de tránsito administrado por el
gobierno y la ONU huyen de los combates
entre el ejército congoleño y el grupo
Rebelde m23 la vence primero las manos y
hagas la fila antes de entrar Marita ha
estado aquí desde hace una semana Y esta
no es su primera vez en uganda la
diferencia es que ahora su casa quedó
destruida huyó de su pueblo durante la
noche con sus hermanas y sus hijos sin
llevarse nada
quiero quedarme aquí para recuperar
energías
estoy traumatizada y tengo hipertensión
por las bombas que pasaban por encima de
nuestras cabezas
mientras tratábamos de escapar Dios nos
protegió las condiciones en este campo
son precarias el centro puede acoger 850
personas pero a menudo su capacidad se
ve desbordada Marita duerme directamente
sobre el suelo aquí
vivo con mis tres hermanas
Estos son nuestros hijos
desde marzo de 2022 las violencias se
han multiplicado en la región de rutsuru
jugando suele ser el único refugio para
estos desplazados puede que algún día
mejoren la situación en nuestro país que
nos volvamos a sentir seguros
esperamos poder regresar a nuestra casa
algún día
los combates entre el grupo armado y los
soldados congoleños han dejado alrededor
de 400.000 personas en la calle una
crisis regional y un reto para el
gobierno ugandés y la uno esta madre
viene de rutsuru
no logramos acoger a todo el mundo en
este momento Entonces Tratamos de usar
refugios temporales los refugiados que
están aquí primero pensaban que al
regresar a la República democrática del
Congo la situación mejoraría pero cuando
regresaron los combates se reanudaron
con fuerza entonces algunos decidieron
volver aquí la ciudad fronteriza de
bonagana Pequeños grupos llegan a uganda
y otros regresan al Congo al territorio
controlado por el m23 a pesar de los
combates perseveren insisten en querer
regresar a sus pueblos como esta familia
huyeron en abril después de nuevo en
noviembre y ahora quieren regresar a
casa Cómo puedo quedarme aquí sin tener
nada donde voy a dormir No tengo dinero
para alquilar una casa
ya no tengo energía para trabajar en los
campos estoy vieja tengo 73 años
cómo voy a sobrevivir aquí para los que
deciden quedarse hasta este año tenía la
posibilidad de instalarse en un gran
campo en yacaban de donde había más de
30.000 personas pero el gobierno lo
cerró a finales de octubre por falta de
financiación este representante local
protestó contra su destrucción
la evacuación se hizo con dureza
imagínense lo que fue con esta temporada
de lluvias con una madre embarazada otra
que no podía caminar los congoleños
quieren venir aquí como lo hacían antes
es su Refugio
pero ahora tiene miedo porque saben que
los estamos esperando con buses para
llevarlos hacia las colonias sin tener
en cuenta lo que nos piden
esa misma mañana los buses ya estaban
listos para salir para descongestionar
el campo mil refugiados serán enviados a
300 kilómetros de su país de origen
llegan aquí vale la colonia para
refugiados más antigua de todo el
continente creada en 1958 este año
24.000 congoleños escogieron ser
reubicados aquí los recién llegados
reciben material para construir su
Refugio
tienen que ir a instalarse allá donde
hay cultivos de maíz y también de
frijoles
Yoselin creció en este campo antes de
ser contratada por una ong de Noruega
sus padres huyeron del Congo hace 10
años durante unos enfrentamientos entre
los mismos actores
estoy segura de que para mis
compatriotas será igual que para mí
recibirán una educación y empezarán una
nueva vida
Jocelyn es optimista pero para otros es
difícil encontrar su lugar en la Colonia
Tomás y su familia llegaron hace dos
meses
antes vivíamos en una tienda de campaña
pero nos fuimos cuando cayeron lluvias
fuertes y hubo inundaciones
un amigo me prestó su casa no tengo
trabajo aquí solo sobrevivió gracias al
frijol al maíz y al aceite que nos da la
ONU con 170.000 refugiados en esta
Colonia de los cuales una gran mayoría
son congoleños distribuidos en 80
pueblos Hay pocas oportunidades para los
recién llegados
antes los refugiados recibían grandes
parcelas de tierra
pero con esta nueva afluencia de
refugiados tan grande
el tamaño de Las parcelas se ha reducido
Entonces tenemos que compartir incluso
esos espacios pequeños actualmente un
tercio de los refugiados en uganda son
congoleños más de 100.000 personas
cruzaron la frontera este año y la ONU
prevé la llegada de 50.000 personas
adicionales para 2023